[Musique]
m.  la robe que vous avez testée positive pour le
VIH l'estimation qu'il reste 30 jours
n'est rien qu'il ne puisse tuer sur une
dérive en 30 jours
alors vient-il de sortir pour le test
et je connais cet hôpital dans les piles
immédiatement
ça ne marche pas  de cette façon, où allez-vous,
ils ont obtenu de bons médicaments du Mexique,
c'est mieux que ce que vous obtenez ici
aux États-Unis,
vous ne pouvez pas acheter cela oui un fruit que vous pouvez
faire faire fortune pour cela, mais
importer des drogues illégales à vendre ils sont
pas illégal,
ils ne sont simplement pas approuvés, puis
vous recherchent Lone Star juste Tinker Bell à
moins que vous n'ayez plus d'argent pour vos
clients Je suis occupé
bienvenue au club des acheteurs de Dallas comment
ils se traitent en vendant de la drogue sur
l'adhésion du vendeur
[Musique]
Amsterdam Donna et
Israël pour faire des affaires avec vous pourquoi
sommes-nous ici
bon restaurant belle femme c'est
là que je me sens à nouveau comme un humain tu n'es
rien de plus qu'un simple trafiquant de
drogue  e
yo ramener à la maison
[Musique]